someone in this movie calls Justin
Bieber the Macaulay Culkin of music what
coked-out washed-up and forgotten give
it time
Justin Bieber Never Say Never
alright so to be clear as for Justin
Bieber the person the kid I don't hate
it
I mean I'm 20-something I got stuff
going for me I don't take time out of my
day to hate an 11 year old I just don't
however all do you the Bieber fever
though yeah hate that until you
die is okay or at least until Bieber's
nuts drop his voice changes and people
forget about him that will happen I hope
that kid invests in stock or something
yes Bieber they will forget about you
well yeah as for the kid I don't hate
him he's a kid he likes to entertain he
was at the right place the right time
the right person saw him and boom he's
obscenely huge good job kid dick being
that he started out on YouTube maybe I
should hate him I mean here we are we
YouTube entertainers were here
entertaining you with whatever talents
we have or we think we have and within a
year this kid's like a zillionaire dick
but this is the same world where William
Hung got famous ish so there is that
that's right Bieber you may have
millions of fans around the world but
you don't have my 23,000 subscribers and
that makes me the richest man on earth
dick I found that when people say they
hate someone like that they usually hate
the hype behind the person or the people
who have made them big in this case the
tweens and middle aged chicks yes all
the movie they're in there which is
strange because if I had that poster on
my wall that would be weird you chicks
got a free pass and you got to admit
that's the Justin Bieber thing
reminds me of the Sam Worthington thing
it's like someone saw him and said you
know what we're gonna take this normal
person make him huge overnight make him
a star make a lot of money I don't like
the sound worthington thing it actually
worked with Bieber there's this producer
that said oh when I met Justin Bieber I
just saw the hair and the clothes and
the tweens and the t-shirts that I could
sell or whatever because it's not about
talent it's about that it's about how
much merchandise you can sell from a 16
year old boy's face that tweens love not
singing talent like it shows him when he
was 12 he was in a singing contest and
he actually lost to this chick where's
she at
apparently she's better than Bieber oh
that's right cause it's not about talent
the Justin Bieber kid he's a kid he's
just living the dream good for him but
the principle behind the that
made him big that pisses me off and what
is this Bieber fever it's out there it's
huge how do you get it cuz i sat through
two hours and having this kid just
shoved down my throat that sounded way
and I still don't have it I don't have
the slightest inkling to buy any of his
crap do you think it's just like well
the results are in you want them let's
have it it appears you have come down
with Bieber fever what don't worry it's
very common among twelve-year-old girls
are you sure the test is 99.9% accurate
so oh god yeah we ran it twice you have
Bieber fever it was just one time it was
just one song well you can only catch it
if you let yourself catch it next time
don't be a fool plug your tool when
we're gonna tell me what am I gonna tell
my wife judging by the diagnosis I
highly doubt that you even have sex with
your wife so there is that this what
time what song don't worry you only have
to put up with it for two years until he
hits puberty and people stop caring I'll
give you a minute now yeah his talent
doesn't justify how huge he is is he
talented yes is he likable yes deserving
of the number1 spot
no I heard his voice he's pretty good I
guess I've seen better people on
American Idol people who will not make
it past Hollywood week shut up we all
have our guilty pleasures this movie
chronicles Justin Bieber's rise to fame
all six weeks of it so this would be the
shortest review ever was interesting
yeah sure but I like autobiographies I
like the new kids on the block
autobiography and I think it was
actually more interesting than this I
mean this movie could have come on TV as
a primetime special it would have been
just fine but how would the douchebag
producer who met Bieber and saw the
haircut and the t-shirt and the twins
and the lunch pails make a zillion and a
half dollars if he didn't release this
movie in theaters in 3d yes Justin
Bieber in 3d two gimmicks one movie like
two girls one cup only a little more
nauseating yeah Jaden Smith is in this
movie he pissed me off more than Bieber
or his haircut ever could because Bieber
ultimately worked to get up there took
him no time but he worked at it and now
he's gonna play in Madison Square Garden
which is pretty much the point of the
movie and Jaden Smith's first
performance of his first concert ever
he's also playing in Madison Square
Garden with Bieber I mean Justin
Bieber's parents pulls no strings I had
no strings to pull there nobody because
Jaden Smith is Will Smith's son because
of his DNA he gets right in it was
interesting seeing him rise to fame all
two weeks of it but after he was famous
he kind of stopped
it's only cool to see like the early
ultimately if you're a Justin
Bieber fan and this is like your Sabbath
if you're not why bother
there's no point but if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more